carlos guillermo la soya es el
presidente de ecuador tras juramentar el
cargo en la ceremonia de investidura
celebrada en el palacio legislativo la
presidenta de la asamblea a guadalupe
llori que es la primera mujer indígena
que dirigirá por dos años el órgano
nacional recibió al lazo y le puso la
banda tricolor presidencial hoy es un
día de celebración histórica porque es
el día de la independencia del ecuador
el día de la libertad y de la república
soberana pero también es un día
histórico porque después de más de una
década se respira la libertad y
democracia es un cambio de mando con
emoción el nuevo dirigente se dirigió al
pueblo ecuatoriano y celebró una
renovación democrática
es un día de rememoración
pero sobre todo es un día de renovación
porque el gobierno que hoy nace tiene
ante sí la responsabilidad de liderar
nos hacia un nuevo siglo del
republicanismo ecuatoriano varios
líderes internacionales acudieron a la
juramentación para dar su apoyo al nuevo
mandatario como el presidente brasileño
jair bolsonaro y el rey de españa felipe
sexto con lazo al frente del país
ecuador comienza una legislatura de
derecha por primera vez en 14 años tras
reemplazar al ex presidente de lenin
moreno de la corriente correísta su
presidencia estará llena de retos como
la profunda crisis económica y sanitaria
que atraviesa el país y que ha golpeado
la economía de una sociedad en la que un
tercio de la población está en situación
de pobreza